(dramatic music)
- I have visual on their ship.
This is organized crime.
- Mexico Narco traffickers call totoaba
the cocaine of the sea.
The fishing of the totoaba
by Chinese traffickers
and Mexican cartels is
killing the vaquita.
The vaquita is getting extinct.
- There were a hundred
and then there were 60,
and now there's fewer than 30.
Come on, sweetie.
Come on, mama.
- [Man In Black] To stop
the killing of the vaquita,
we have to take down those traffickers.
The whole thing stinks.
It is corruption all the way.
Who is...
- [Woman] There are some
really bad guys here.
They don't wanna see us succeed.
(placid music)
- [Man In Black] If we
don't save the vaquita,
we will lose the most
beautiful places of the planet.
I keep thinking about the moment
when only one vaquita
will be left in the wild.
- [Man In Blue] This is a war against
the extinction of a species.
- [Woman] We have to hold onto the hope
that it's gonna work.
- [Man] The poachers are unacceptable.
They'll take any means necessary.
- Clock's ticking.
- [Man] We will fight
for every single life.
We won't stop.
(mysterious music)
(water lapping)